well guys that is Super Bowl day or as I
like to call it awesome movie trailer
day because I enjoy football but I'm
really there for the commercials
especially since I'm from Cleveland and
right now the Ravens are winning and
apparently the only way for the Browns
to ever win a Super Bowl is if they
transform into another team Cleveland
rant over
I saw a few trailers I saw oz the great
and powerful I'm not terribly interested
in that movie Fast & Furious 6 though I
am now that sounds weird for me to say
even coming out of my mouth simply
because I've never really been a huge
fan of The Fast and the Furious movies
until Fast Five Fast Five came along and
I remember when I saw posters for that
movie in the theater I was like really
why and then when I saw Fast Five it
totally took the series in a different
direction it wasn't just your standard
racing movie some hardcore fans of the
series were upset about that I like the
fact they took it in a different
direction made it more of a heist film
added more comedy in there and some
really well filmed action that's why I'm
looking forward to fast six because it
looks like they're going in that same
direction more of a crime like film with
more heists and more over-the-top action
of course in this trailer you see cars
fly out of airplanes cars are flipping
everywhere Dwayne Johnson Gina Carano
Paul Walker Vin Diesel of course is back
I'm kind of pumped about this movie
simply for one reason it is that kind of
movie that you go to that tells you okay
it's officially summer now it looks like
one of those movies that understands
what it is and relishes it for that and
I'm really hoping that it stays that way
because I don't want them to take
themselves too seriously because Fast
Five really understood that level of
over-the-top action that they could ride
on while also just being a
straightforward entertaining film and
that film really surprised me for those
reasons and I'm hoping that Fast and
Furious 6 does the same and I think this
is the perfect vehicle for gina carano
right now because she did a great job
with the action sequences in haywire
this is the kind of movie that she needs
to be in a movie where she can really
shine in a supporting role and you can
just like her but she's not like
required to give an oscar-worthy
performance of some kind I think this is
a good role for her I'm looking forward
to Fast and Furious 6 I'm not expecting
much out of it in the sense that it's
just supposed to be an entertaining
action film what do you guys think of
the trailer what do you think of the
game right now I'm gonna be back with
reviews for the Star Trek 2 trailer and
the Iron Man 3 trailer as always guys
thanks for watching if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck Manoj
you believe in ghosts